What can you do with an?
Lots of things.
Imagine that you have a model
that predicts the next step
of your sequence, for example.
You can use that to generate sequences.
For example, text, either one word at
a time or one character at a time.
For that, you take your sequence at
time, t, you generate the predictions
from your RNN, and then you sample
from the predicted distribution.
And then you pick one element
based on its probability.
And feed that sample to
the next step and go on.
Do this repeatedly, predict,
sample, predict, sample, and
you can generate a pretty good
sequence of whatever your RNN models.
There is a more sophisticated way to
do this, that gives better results.
Because just sampling the next
prediction every time, is very greedy.
Instead of just sampling
once at each step,
you could imagine
sampling multiple times.
Here we pick O but also A for example.
When we have multiple sequences,
often call that hypotheses,
that you could continue
predicting from at every step.
You can choose the best sequence out
of those, by computing the total
probability of all the characters
that you generated so far.
By looking at the total probability
of the multiple time steps at a time.
You prevent the sampling from
accidentally making one by choice, and
being stuck with that one
bad decision forever.
For example, we could have just
picked A by chance here, and
never explored the hypothesis that O
could lead to a very sensible next word.
Of course, if you do this the number
of sequences that you need to consider
grows exponentially.
There is a smarter way to do that, which
is to do what's called a Beam Search.
You only keep, say, the most likely few
candidate sequences at every time step,
and then simply prune the rest.
In practice, this works very well for
generating very good
sequences from your model.